okay so let's let's get into some of the
politics stuff so every all my people
know my situation with the left but you
have been in a very similar situation
with the right I know a couple of people
in a similar situation as you but
basically your sense I think is that the
Trump situation is sort of hijacked the
party nobody's really talking about
issues anymore it's really just become
personality driven this is why Milo
loves it actually and I can and I can
get on board some of that because it's
so against you know the social justice
warriors and all that and I like that
part of it well you're a policy guy and
that's why you do these videos breaking
down policy and calling out [ __ ] and
all that so so is that really what
you're struggling with here that it's
not this election almost has nothing at
least on the Republican side has nothing
to do with policy well it's not a
struggle for me at all
I mean that's one thing I have a
complete respect for people who say you
know I'm gonna Democrat I'm not a
Republican I just want someone who's
going to come in and piss people off and
I'm angry so I'm voting for Trump that's
fine I have no problem with it I have
much I don't want to say a problem but I
have far less respect for people who
have claimed to be tea party
conservatives or Christian conservatives
doing these sort of mental gymnastics to
justify the actions of somebody who
basically wants to come in and take the
greatest power grab the executive office
has had if you look at his proposals not
once has Donald Trump stance urban I
don't think the government can fix this
every now and then every now and then
wouldn't it just be good to hear
politicians say no yeah damn yeah that
sucks I really know if I can fix it for
you right so like to hear someone say
that so that's why you you would want a
real Libertarian candidate than you
would you vote for Gary Johnson if we if
he was a legit third party guy if he
could get into the debate at 15% would
you go for him well I've said this if
it's Trump versus Hillary probably just
because I don't believe at this point I
think there's a you know two sides of
the same coin I don't believe any of
them are pro-life I know Gary Johnson is
not pro-life but I genuinely believe
that he probably attempts to defund
Planned Parenthood I know he has no
choice I'm a big supporter of the
two-party system because it come from
Canada which is a parliamentary
the reason the two-party system exists
is to avoid this quagmire that you see
in the primary where someone can hijack
a party and can't get over that 36%
ceiling of the vote um listen I thought
Donald Trump coming in like he said I
like that he pisses off the right people
that's great
I get it I like that he's coming in and
he's speaking in a way that the use of
the media just they don't know what to
do all these analysts and talking ads I
mean that's how I got on Fox News at 21
and I would just go on and like make fun
of them and they didn't know how to
handle it because this is how you
conduct a debate at a roundtable so I
understand all that but at a certain
point I was saying I need to hear
something anything at any point
espousing some kind of constitutional
conservatism and and I haven't seen that
I don't care if things are ugly I don't
care if people are politically divided
listen I'm fine with being politically
divided over the right issues if someone
wants to ban students for using
offensive words on campus or they want
to enact speech laws I'm fine with being
politically divisive with that person
but I also do think like you know we
agree on that but there are certain
issues maybe you can help me with this
yeah I've never heard a single leftist
rationalization that makes sense good I
get it pro-life okay you're pro you
don't think it's murder there's science
and both sigh understand it health care
you think you're entitled to everything
for free courtesy of my tax dollars is a
human right because Bernie Sanders says
so I can understand how you justify that
but how can anyone on the Left be
against for example charter schools or a
voucher program attached to the student
as opposed to no choice in them to the
school how can I left to speak against
drug testing or working for welfare as
we saw in Mississippi okay you want it
you want to get your welfare you show up
your work we place you in a job we put
you in a job placement program I've
never heard a rational argument against
some key issues and it always reverts
back to more government power and I
think that both of us who have a problem
with both George Bush and Barack Obama
and this executive power grab should
feel incredibly uncomfortable with the
rhetoric from people like Hillary
Clinton or Bernie or Trump but I know
you're not a Cruz guy but all of those
people he's the one saying he'll do the
least or Gary Johnson I guess that's
what Cruz is saying he just reeks of me
of used-car salesman of the worst kind I
I don't I get what you're saying and we
can get into a couple of those issues so
we'll talk about some of our differences
on those issues but
to me is just and this is I mean this
more at like not a policy place or
gut-level I mean it just at a gut level
I watch him in those debates there is
something so slimy about him and you
know this this thing that what does he
have finally he got one guy in the
Senate to back him I think Jeff Sessions
or maybe one or two others now have been
sort of first into it or I think Lindsey
Graham systematically endorsed everyone
else first and then the day that he
would endorse people they would drop out
I'm pretty sure now he's that's the ship
that Trump people claim they like right
he's gonna he's gonna go and he's gonna
piss everybody off no he doesn't they're
all willing to work with him all the
Democrats the widely acknowledged that
he's a much more of a deal maker these
unprincipled and Ted Cruz they hate him
because he went in any submission picado
you're a liar hey john bainer you're
kind of a piece of crap I like that I
don't want a guy who's going in to make
friends at this point I understand it
and it's a valid criticism but it's the
same thing they used to praise Trump
when it's untrue and then criticized
Cruz yeah he's unliked he's polarizing
because he is the outsider and in I
understand that I actually like that but
I also understand you know you need
someone who can work with both sides and
what are you thinking about what do you
think about him on just that gut level
cuz a lot of people what I'm saying
about that just that feeling about him
you get a feeling about all of these
people and I can gladly tell you my
feelings about the rest of them but like
you just saw rise get a feeling about
them and I think most people are with me
on this what do you think about that
well I think the media's done a really
unfair here I think a good example right
is it kind of studying home state Ted
Cruz versus Marco Rubio Ted Cruz won his
home state overwhelmingly Marco Rubio
lost it by a big margin because people
voted for Ted Cruz he did exactly what
he said he was going to do people were
happy with him where's Marco Rubio sort
of betrayed his voting constituency and
I like Marco Rubio but he kind of
screwed the pooch in the gang of eight
so I think it's important to know okay
we feel that way but has he been
consistent and how do people who voted
for him who said okay you have the job
feel about him what do they think about
him and the numbers are incredibly
consistent yeah I agree with you I only
had him on the show and actually on our
show is where he was the best he was a
little bit loose in the shoulders yes
it's that way where well let me tell you
a story and they
okay get it and then Donald Trump toe
says you know he's a prick he's a lying
piece of [ __ ]
and people like that right well Cruz
always crews always tells the he tells a
joke and then when he releases the
punchline at the end you're like wait
did you get to the punchline like you
know like there's never but you're a
comedian that's not fair I mean you know
if Hillary Clinton tells a joke it
usually involves you know devouring
someone's head on the stage so they both
have their weaknesses when it comes to
delivering a punchline but I certainly
wouldn't say it's it's unfounded if you
could just take a a better delivery I
understand that gut level I mean I've
had him on the program I've dealt with
his people and they were always very
very honest and very professional and
we've dealt with a lot of candidates on
the show so I can sit out on a personal
level and then on a record on a policy
record the guy's been pretty consistent
he wasn't my first choice but you know
here we are so I suspect if it ended up
being Cruz verse Bernie in a way that's
sort of your that's sort of your dream
situation right because then there is a
clear battle of ideas like if you if you
get Hillary and Trump we know that
really they're both centrists and Trump
you know it'd be the reason we don't
know what he thinks about anything is
because he's taking every position
because he just wants to win I get it
and Hillary has done a lot of the same
thing but you really like the Bernie
even though you would you would hate
Bernie as president but you like the
idea that Bernie Cruz thing because then
we can go here's a set here's the what
is the role of government and let's have
it out oh yeah I think would be a
beautiful election answer this
puritanical sense of okay you have pure
socialism and you do have constitutional
conservatism and listen I'm not going to
lie it's a little scary that socialism
might win in the United States hello
they say lads its democratic socialism
with democratic slavery Democratic
dictatorship you can bring someone in
through democracy and then it destroys
everything it doesn't make it any nicer
democratic I don't know Arby's it's
still Arby's no one wants to go to
Arby's but if people democratically
elect that everyone eats Arby's it
doesn't mean it's a good thing so that's
this sort of sleight of hand that he's
pulled by just adding Democratic in
front of it but yeah I would like to see
that I would for all of Bernie's faults
he's been relatively respectful of of
Hillary Clinton he could go after her in
a way that Donald Trump could only hope
to after these
publican candidate so he has to make
stuff up Bernie doesn't do it he sticks
to policy he sticks to disagreement and
I do think that with him and Cruz you'd
have a contrast so I know it's just sort
of the political hobbyist in me but yeah
I'd much rather see that than Trump and
Hillary Clinton by the way if it's Trump
versus Hillary I think he's gonna I
think he's gonna turn heel you know as
we say in wrestling and I don't I don't
think he's going to be as hard on
Hillary as he's been on Republicans I
think they have too much dirt on each
other sort of mutually assured
destruction I could be wrong no I like I
agree with that I agree with that I
think I think also that he would know
that she's the only one that would be
able to counter some of his stuff you
know the little mark rice stuff or
nobody likes Ted Cruz or Jeb you can't
get it up or whatever else he was saying
about these guys I think Hillary for all
it's a little bit of opining on you was
that a bit did I stretch that one never
boned your wife Orson I don't know
somebody whatever it is but I think that
that he knows Hillary for all the flaws
she has which are obviously many she is
so seasoned and so good and if she had
to sit there across from Trump I think
it would be the first time that he would
be back on his heels a little bit we've
seen him back on his heels and it was it
was Carly Fiorina well so right so you
get that you get the woman element there
where there's a woman element it was
just someone with balls
Carly Fiorina was the only other one
listen I know people don't I liked Carly
Fiorina why I thought she was
conservative enough and I thought she
could beat Hillary Clinton and she is
someone who you ask a question she will
answer that question what are they
running the company into a ground thing
did that bother me let's see what
happens in two years with Aurra
you never know Dan I'll blame it on you
now listen you can just take over aura
is that way you're done with CEO pay
let's say companies losing eight hundred
million a year and they bring in a new
CEO they're losing 400 million years
yeah but sluicing 400 million less and
if you look at HP compared to other
companies that we're developing I mean
also during that time the iPhone was
created right things rapidly evolve not
a lot of tech companies it doesn't mean
she's a great CEO but at Donald Trump
isn't a great businessman either but
yeah I understand the flaws we asked her
about that on the show
point-blank and she
I said listen you're tenured HP is not
impressive how do you answer your
critics and she went boom boom boom boom
down the list and she answered it in a
way that I thought was adequate hey my
point to say is we did see Donald Trump
back up when he made fun of her face and
then on stage - by the way she's got a
great face that's the closest you get to
an apology from Donald Trump so you've
had a bunch of these guys on you've had
huckabee on you've had cruz you might
just guys you sexist prick guys and gals
you've had huckabee you've had cruz
you've had gals you have a madman
haircut you're talking like you from the
early sixties a chick how about a chick
can i say that without that that's going
to upset your nose be the nature's that
work exactly
have you had any of the other anyone
else cruz huckabee gosh I want to we had
Santorum on at some point I don't I
don't know exactly we've extended
invitations to all of them yeah and
Trump obviously won't come on they don't
really like the impressions and I don't
I don't know I'd have to get back but
those are the ones that you know stood
out because at that point there were
sort of transitioning from second stage
to first stage or they were kind of
surging so those are the ones that stick
stick in mind and I don't think many of
them will come back I mean you can only
have a presidential candidate come up
and then someone goes did you do this
show we're in the very next segment
Crowder play and that's why I don't want
to endorse anyone because that will do
more harm than good
right so I've watched your interviews
with those three and what I thought you
did do well is no it's a it's a really
slippery game interviewing these people
and this is where the mainstream media
has failed miserably they asked softball
questions constantly because they want
to get a second interview and they want
a third interview and a fourth interview
and Chuck Todd knows if he stands up in
the White House press room not that
Obama does a lot of press conferences
anymore or ever but if he asks a tough
question then Obama's just gonna turn to
somebody else or this is the list in
front of him because I think he's picked
right off a predetermined list he's just
gonna go elsewhere right but I I have
noticed that you you've tried your best
to go in and out and I know when I'm
interviewing people that are not as
influential as presidential candidates
sometimes you have to my policy is I'll
ask a sort of more broad question
because I want to hear people's thoughts
and then let them hang them
cells if that's where they're gonna go
but how aware are you of that when
you're talking to them like oh I want to
get this guy back or you know I'm gonna
do the segment after or any of that
stuff well well it's funny you said you
don't give him kind of enough rope to
hang themselves we had to change our
policy after one of our guests was
caught masturbating in the closet and
hung himself so we said that we maybe
played this poorly overplay our hand I
you know no one karate'd themselves in
the studio aside from that game okay oh
I guess that was so awkward when I was
watching that movie life as a house and
it was Hayden Christensen and there was
that scene where he's choking himself in
the closet and my girlfriend at the time
and her mom like oh my gosh it's so sad
he's trying to kill himself no no no I
think I think you're missing the concept
of the scene like what are you talking
about an ID to explain them like people
do that you a good Christian
conservative had to explain that to your
poor wife that that is very sick no
wonder my wife was a girl for at the
time and I also had to explain to them
that that World War two happened because
they were actually German and I was
watching Saving Private Ryan wants it
off so is that kind of a serious German
family
the question was yeah you know my thing
is and I think you're good about this
too ask them give them the ability to
answer and if they don't follow up hold
them to it and my job is not to have
them back that's not my job my job is to
get the questions answered that I think
the audience wants to hear and I you
know I try and do the best job of it
that I can this is not something I
signed up for when I was you know
planning a career I'm grateful to have
the opportunity and and I will say you
know Carly and in Ted we're very good in
answering the questions when they felt
that their guard was a little bit down
and and that impressed me and that's
what we don't have we don't have a lot
of local politicians or any of this
stuff you know it's it's a podcast that
happens to be syndicated on radio and
the problem with you know traditional
media is these people they send out
these press releases you get like 20 a
day begging for some state rep to be on
and I just listen we're not going to do
it our job is to entertain the audience
to inform the audience if it's not
entertaining informative or insightful
it gets scrapped from the program so
that's how we try and run it